I told you guys the the Antipa story
right when they didn't recognize me I
think so
I probably didn't love him in Germany no
no no this one's in New York okay I
don't know this one I've told it often
so I'll be quick with it I mean made us
a lot of people who don't are familiar
but Mike Stern de vich was speaking at
Columbia University in New York so I
decide to go check it out and I've
actually spoken there too I was invited
like PhD programs at Columbia several
times so I'm like I'll go bring my
camera and I'll film stuff so I'm in
this this Lobby with you know I don't
know hundred protestors and they're all
yelling you know my turn about y'all we
hate the guy or whatever and I'm just
standing there like my eyes are half
closed glazed over like it's boring
whatever yeah
when all sudden someone yells Tim Poole
is alt right or something like that okay
and they all start looking around
confused because nobody knows who I am
yeah so you know I did I started looking
around confused too they couldn't figure
it out good move and so they all start
the guy points towards me and everyone
looks so I turn with the camera and look
to like I get a dude that you you don't
want to single yourself out to people
who don't know what's going on so I'm
like oh I were they talking about you
know and the guy he put his hand over
like this guy no one knows it's
happening and all of a sudden some
random dude so it's yelling yeah walks
up to some journalists on the other side
of the room an old guy wearing a fast to
the camera and he starts yelling um it's
you you people are the problem you're
and everyone's like confused and the
journalists like points himself like me
like I don't notice and I'm like I'm
filming and then finally the guy comes
up and he's like this is Tim Poole and
then they all turn around and start
yelling at me and I saw I was laughing
I'm like these people have no idea who I
am
they're they're just saying whatever
they were told to say it's it's that's
how I messed up these people are so you
know when it comes to jancuga of the
young turks calling Trump a fascist when
Trump says to actually relinquish
government power yeah what is you know
what man I'm just I'm just trying to
make sense of everything and you know
he's had this this power for a long
while now and really hasn't used it you
know he won't I know it's like if he if
he got the power and instantly started
using it they would have flipped out the
other life they would have flipped and
been like he's crazy he's finally done
it he's going off the rails but then he
was like you know yeah it hasn't really
has he even used
once I think I think use it once one
time that the masks right so they to
make 3m keep their masks here and bring
the ones from overseas Becky right right
and that's like and then you know what
that makes sense well I mean not even
mad
they actually they've been calling the
guy a fascist for years and the dudes
clearly not a fascist I mean look the
United Sates is a the United States has
authoritarianism you know in various
respects in through the whole government
yeah yeah in various areas typically
like our law enforcement you the
craziest thing to me is I in the early
2010's the the entirety of the left was
mistrusting of the intelligence agencies
yeah CIA in the FBI and the NSA yet the
Edward Snowden leaks you know several
years back and then and then something
strange happened the intelligence
agencies started going up against Trump
and all of a sudden they were heroes and
everyone loved them yeah it's a good
point but though here's the problem I
have with people like Genki ogre he's a
progressive he's a Bernie Sanders guy
right yeah he's not really the actual
progressives have no problem calling out
the intelligence agencies calling out
Russia gate Glenn Greenwald is a good
example
he's the intercept he's the guy who
released the NSA documents Oh God here
agged on all of them all of the media
forever the whole time and he hates
Trump but he knows the media's full of
it he knows the intelligence agents
agencies are full of it so I disagree
with him on certain things but he's
being honest about the press and the
intelligence agencies but people like
jancuga
who immediately come out and say Trump
is a fascist and we believe all these
things the media is lying
and then the media lies about him to try
and stop him from running for Congress
yeah they smeared him all these awful
things and then he just keeps toeing the
line he's like a fake progressive he
says it's progressive he says it's for
Bernie and then he really just agrees
with whatever the mainstream media says
even though we know that they're full of
it most of the time it's because it
works
oh yeah bling-bling man that's that's
why I mean look there's nobody you can
see it when when he talks he loves it
he's like I love this when he films
themselves you're listening to me right
now I love it yeah and then it just kind
of it's noticeable after a while when
films himself don't you know I may be
honest when he said the airplane and
he's like can you believe they're not
letting me me of all people on this
plane it's like
are you seriously going there dude like
look at I no longer care about you it
was already pretty slim anyway but man
when you when someone tries claiming
that by giving up government authority
or demanding an end to government
authority that they're a fascist you
know I'm gonna I'm just gonna give you a
loaf like come on just look over there
and do you know what the word fascist
means clearly the first thing I'd asked
them so I I mean that the best example
of the dude clearly not being legit is
that he Union busted his own company I
know that's is the it's the craziest
thing you know what Shane Smith of Vice
said when when his employees were
unionizing what he's like hey great cool
good that's awesome he was like I'm
excited for it sounds awesome that
should be and and he's I don't want to
speak for him cuz he's never I've never
actually asked him about his political
bleeding's but people usually referred
him is more like a libertarian guy okay
not like a no hardcore like right
libertarian but like goodbye if I get
very very capitalist libertarian you'd
think if you took vice which is just
cutthroat capitalist I'm it's the
company's notorious for I mean they
eventually got woke you took that guy
and you took John Kyogre and asked which
one would Union bust you'd think people
would be like oh that the the
billionaire guy who's like at this
massive company that does all these
crazy clickbait documentaries yeah no
actually he supported the Union and then
they eventually unionized and Jenk
apparently yelled at some dude through
papers on the ground start Yellin fired
the guy seriously fired the guy claimed
it was for something else of course yeah
this dude's a fake progressive he's a
capitalist all the way it's the same
thing we saw with Mike calm which I
talked about a couple days ago they were
they were you know they're capitalists
bless their hearts want to make some
money made some some far-left content to
manipulate these people you know what it
is men hmm if if you try and be honest
you got a challenge if I if I don't if
you don't believe the ends justify the
means and so you having a real
conversation with someone you're
unwilling to lie that's a tough so now
if you're willing to lie you can sell
anything
yeah I guess that's something that the
if you want to sell something well they
do they want to sell ads yeah something
those I blow they're not being honest
then combine what we just talked about
with all those people dancing yeah with
people like
huger and what do you get they find a
crowd of people they put a few people in
there start yelling things like we love
Bernie and then everyone else who says
oh yeah me too yeah and I just look over
here everybody you want to fit in watch
this and they play the commercial and
they make money and then when their
staff is like hey we'd like to Hey his
staff goes we agree with you we'd like
to unionize too he goes what nod Mary
throws his papers down I'm a little
biased though because Genk yelled at me
I don't know if you guys really
politican please tell me so there was
this us this paper that came out that
was totally fake news and guy arguing
that there was a group called the
alternative influence network and they
put me right in the middle of this big
conspiracy crime web of all these lines
connect to each other the whole thing
was fake that's kind of fun though it's
but it mean it's insane and it's been
it's been detrimental it's probably the
reason why my YouTube channels
blacklisted from Google oh because many
of the people on that list immediately
got blacklisted the lower the lower
lesser known personalities the higher
profile ones like Joe Rogan they didn't
touch yeah but so this this thing comes
out they put me in the middle
they had there's a guy named Chris
Reagan yeah you know he has YouTube
comedian he does don't think so
he's a youtuber he does videos with like
a little toy llama and he makes jokes
and he sometimes talk about it but it's
just he plays video games and he hangs
of his friends and it's like silly stuff
sounds like my kind of guy they claimed
that he had collaborated with a guy
named Richard Spencer one of the like
most well-known nouns familiar he's like
the guy coined alt-right popularized it
yeah very prominent white nationalist
think I can envision his face it's
ridiculous that they would claim these
guys had ever done anything together and
they did and they used manipulative ran
with it and so the story comes out and
the Young Turks because they hate Dave
Rubin mmm Dave Rubin used to be on The
Young Turks so they hate him and they
ran a smear of him and they used this as
proof that Dave was part of a nefarious
group of people who and I saw the
thumbnail and sure enough there's my
name right in the middle and I'm
watching I'm like you gotta put my name
right in the middle screen there
ringleader so I sent him a message
because uh I know Anna and and Jenk and
I've you know I've been there show a
couple times and I asked them I was like
hey you know I wonder how are things
going just want to let you know like
this is not true and you guys were doing
this thing about Dave I don't know
anything about your criticism of Dave or
anything like that but I'm just
wondering if you'd be willing to leave
my name out of whatever you guys are
doing yeah
they ignored me so when I was at
política in LA I was up in this like
media area and I saw Jen he was talking
to somebody oh my god it's Jana
you know I've talked to him before I
talked to my VidCon a couple years ago
he shook my hand how's it going man good
to see you again and I saw him and I was
like hey Jen yeah quick sign I don't ask
you something he goes no I don't have
any time you know
and I was like no this is this is
serious man you guys ran a story he was
fake news and it smeared me yeah and
then he just snapped
really what you're talking about you
know you're a trump supporter what is
this and he just went off on me and
tried stamping I'm like whoa whoa whoa
whoa dude what oh it was a craziest
thing I was like I was like I didn't say
anything I'm and then we went at it for
a little bit and I was like I have like
why are you yelling at me what's
happening right now and then finally I
was like I was like dude I have no idea
you're talking about he started bringing
up like my criticism of an tyfa and he's
like I don't see you complaining about
Trump and I'm like what does that have
to do with people being violent in the
streets and he's like okay fine whatever
and I was like dude all I was gonna ask
you is that you guys ran a hit on Dave
and you put my name on I'm just asking
you not to do that it goes fine get any
points like an assistant get his email
we'll figure it out and I'm like nah so
then this BBC crew film the whole thing
oh they were in the room filming it was
it was a hallway and so the BBC crew
followed him in barks fly between Tim
Poole and saying cougar I mean barely
sparks for me the dudes just screaming
at me but the the the the BBC guys went
in and is what I was told I don't know
exactly what happened but they asked
they said hey we filmed that whole thing
you know for you know posterity or
whatever for you know journalism we want
to make sure you have a chance to
comment and they basically said GTFO or
else and so they came out and they would
talk to me and they were like we phone
the whole thing they wouldn't give us a
comment they actually kicked us out
yeah sounds it sounds about right
yep so look man take that story I don't
what he was yelling about I don't know
why he was mad yeah he just snapped on
me I I hadn't I'd never really talked to
the guy got she got trigger for
something you want to run fake news you
know and just take without fact-checking
some story I named it the mainstream
media's but they're but they're not even
mainstream I know I'm generalizing does
that know you I'm know it's funny man
I'm I'm gonna go there I really really
go there
Jane cougar likes to brag about his
viewership I wouldn't normally say yeah
it's what he's to talk do announced
Witter he's like let me see if I can
find this tweet he did he's all mad
because they said let me let me find
this tweet
it's a story saying Joe Biden is losing
the Internet here we go check this out
he said I'm so tired of MSM being
oblivious to what happens on YouTube and
then writing think pieces about how
dominant right wing is the Young Turks
has more views than top five right wing
channels combined on YouTube Democrats
aren't dominant but progressives are all
right The Young Turks you're so cool
think if you take their so they have a
network and I think it's fair to say if
you combine the views of all their
network sure I think they get like 50
million views that's that's a lot sure
yeah he says the top five right-wing
channels combined on YouTube steven
crowder gets like 40 million dude the
daily wire gets easily a million yeah
well he didn't put those on there a
million what then this wouldn't be true
so 40 40 views in a month so I don't
know exactly what the what the Young
Turks get on Google but let me let me do
this wait we were talking about the
governor's abusing power right yeah yeah
all right check this out
so the Young Turks main channel with
four point seven million viewers gets
thirty four point three four four
million views now okay they they get
about a million 1.3 million per day
watch out Young Turks we're coming for
you no I'm not coming buddy no but if
you want to come out and complain and
smack talk and talk about how big you
are when it's not even true you're the
biggest it's like come on so they have a
network I think it's fair to point out
if you combine all their channels they
probably get many more millions but they
got four point eight million four point
seven million subscribers on their
channel and they're getting 34 million
let's see if I can pull up steven
crowder i'd be curious about the daily
wire to then in that context combined
Crowder's cool I just started found a
month ago and he's got he's funny guy
funny YouTube Wow this takes a really
long time because of uh here we go
steven crowder has got twenty five point
eight six five with four point four
million so he's he's almost got them by
himself he's down about a third or so I
know but by himself well I'll tell you
what yeah I've got six hundred thousand
subs not four point seven million yeah
and I get twenty seven twenty eight
million views on my on my Tim cast news
channel that's cuz you know what you
know how that is quality right there I
don't I don't know this guy quality so
all right I'll say it I look at my god
the channels we have so I've got I've
got four channels three of them are me
hosting content by myself whoa your your
border in a line of talking about how
many viewers you guys I'm gonna go there
all right go for it is I want to make a
point it's poking at you this is why you
don't go around bragging about how big
your viewership is yeah because the
Young Turks puts up like fifteen videos
per day on their on their channel mm-hmm
and they get thirty four thirty three
four thirty four million
I put five videos a third of the videos
and I get sixty five sixty six percent
of the views they get so hey if I if I
doubled up you know put five more videos
up then I'd be getting more than them
with only two thirds of the content
better yet I put up a total of six
videos per day if you include my main
channel I'm getting like forty two
million views per month so I'm getting
more than them with less than half of
the amount of content produced quality I
don't I don't I don't care about the
reason I'm not gonna go around Brett
bring us up being like Tim food gets
both his views get me on this airplane
clearly it's gone to his head the dude
runs a business it's successful enough
he doesn't want a staff to unionize he's
pretending he's progressive I think it's
funny when they're like to pool Perkins
pretends to be on the left I'm like I
don't care what you think of me I
I handle my life the way I hand on my
life you I got Ramos some pretend to be
on the left go talk to the dude who who
just Union busted his own company yeah
exactly
well we somehow got off of Governors uh
yeah I heard about that union busting
thing before I saw the airplane video
and I was like that is ridiculous that's
my airplane video all Mars trying to do
to their company their employees and
it's like no this is this is the worst
like you these are good
they tried claiming it was a it was a
smear campaign from his Democratic
opponent to make him look bad during the
campaign or something like that really
something like that
yeah no no the the union-busting oh yeah
he was like the the people coming out
smearing him we're like tied to his
opponent or whatever and I'm like yeah
probably that's that's the Democratic
Party sounds about right I mean that's
politics in general everyone does that
yeah tell me again about how you're the
outside anti-establishment character
who's just parroting everything they say
yeah you know a man there there's a
media establishment that he tries to be
a part of that's what's really like
annoying about it he goes around
bragging about his viewership you know
he's doing he's going to the media and
being like can I be in your club yeah I
get a bunch of views - why won't you
write about me yeah it's like you're so
right that's true that's what he's doing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you